you think it's matter from Kings murder
what can I do to help her story is one
of the most original video games of the
year the graphics consist of a police
database and interrogation videos that's
all there is to it but it's enough to
captivate gamers the world over
it was dreamed up by English developer
Sam Barlow the game appeared on the
market in late June sales have already
passed the 100,000 mark when you play
the game you're sat in front of
essentially a police computer from 1994
so that's kind of old fashioned computer
desktop and when you start the game
there's already this kind of a pope of
this database app which allows you to
search through this police database and
within this database there are lots and
lots of clips of the police interviewing
this one woman over the course of seven
interviews talking about her missing
husband both form and content are a
radical departure from the mainstream
game production her story is an
independent game it has no publisher no
big studio behind it only an actress and
a database that was Sam Barlow's concept
after 13 years working in the gaming
industry he went independent especially
for this project traditionally the
publishers always had the power because
they've owned the infrastructure they
vote the distribution networks now that
you can actually just you know start a
company one day and within a couple of
weeks have you know you can literally
put something up on the app store or
something and sell it like that her
story is sold only online through
platforms like Steam gamers pay about
six euros nearly seventy percent of
which goes to the developer a
trailblazer for indie game creators was
minecraft it was developed by a
freelance programmer and distributed by
hundreds of thousands of devoted players
on YouTube sales are now in the millions
microsoft recently acquired the rights
for over two billion euros some
independent game colleges have been able
to compete against the big publisher
owned companies because they can get
market directly to the consumers they
can get youtubers to play their games
and this can result in the game being
seen by millions of potential players
the budget is the most obvious
difference between indie games and big
Studio productions bungees latest
first-person shooter game destiny cost a
good 150 million euros to develop by
contrast her story took a mere ninety
thousand euros what financial support
Sam Barlow got came from other
developers the big publisher instigator
making trouble a games are spending
millions of dollars but it's not
possible of course to make games at a
much smaller proportion of the cost so
the cost is formed and the ability to
get to market has increased Sam Barlow
worked on his game her story for a whole
year it made its development costs back
within 23 days success was not taken for
granted but it's the idea that makes or
breaks an independent game and the
courage to see it through I was thinking
I want to do something that is all the
things I'm not allowed to do if I'm
working for a publisher so all the
things that are going to get vetoed by a
green light committee or focus groups
whatever you know these are the things
that I'm able to do now because no one
has to give me permission her story is
likely to be just one of many more to
come from the likes of Sam Barlow a
wake-up call to the big studios shift